qu' on ne sacrifie pas toujours
uniquement à l'aérodynamique
on sacrifie aussi à la mode et quand la
mode est conforme aux lois de
l'aérodynamique ça va très bien mais ne
l'est pas toujours
par exemple dans la mesure où on se
rapproche toujours du corps idéal
on a sacrifié à l'air au titanic plus
qu'à la mode il faut aussi évidemment
sacrifier à la pratique souvent pour
donner la visibilité aux pilotes des
tout ne pas détruire abîmé un peu cette
ligne là mais lorsque par exemple on
arrange les lignes de telle façon qu à
l'arrière on est un angle comme ceux ci
qui provoquent des tourbillons ou qu'à
l'avant on donne des angles tel aux
calandres que les filets d'air et
beaucoup de mal à passer
là on sacrifie de tête à une mode mais
on ne suit pas les règles de
l'aérodynamique
d'ailleurs c'est très simple il faut
toujours se mettre à la place du fils
est d'ailleurs supposer que vous soyez
le filet d'air bas il vaut mieux
rencontrer un corps comme ça on a
quelques chances de s'en sortir par
elissalde
si vous rencontrez des corps comme ça
vous êtes détruits et bien le filet
d'air lui aussi n'est pas détruit mais
il fait et à tourbillon et vous faites
payer ça quand vous passez à la pompe à
essence
en réalité ce qui donne au dessinateur
de carrosserie de liberté assez grande
s'éclairant dynamique tout appuyé sur
les mathématiques n'est pas une science
exacte
l'expérimentation joue un grand rôle
dans l'établissement de ses impératifs
airs mais quelquefois ses conclusions en
cause ce qui rend un peu la bride à
l'imagination et permettent aux
constructeurs de créer des mods pour
notre plaisir où notre agacement
c'est en soufflerie autant et plus que
sur le papier qu'on étudie la résistance
à l'air les nouveaux modèles de grande
série ce film a été pris lors des essais
sur maquette de la dauphine la mise en
route d'une chaîne produisant des autos
par milliers exige de longer prudent
préliminaire
le profil de cette voiture est née sur
le papier son apparence à trois
dimensions est sorti de la glaise comme
une ébauche de sculpteurs comme le
sculpteur
le styliste a cherché ce que
l'imagination et de nous pouvait donner
d'après un objet fait pour plaire
l'esthétique automobile personne ne peut
admirer l'évolution
s'il s'intéresse aux arts vivants
résultats de ces recherches doit
constituer ce que les publics appellent
bo doit faire une moyenne entre les
opinions différentes des clients les
plus disparates doit gagner sur le plan
esthétique une bataille commerciale
après la maquette d'argile le modèle
grandeur nature en plâtre auquel seront
apportées aux ciseaux les dernières
retouches
ainsi même un style qui parle monde
soutiendra le prestige d'une signature
mais qu'est ce qu'un style en matière
d'automobile